so today we're going to take a look at
oaworth
and what is over
well it is a way for us to make a really
simple sign up process
and the way that it works is that the
user clicks
sign in or sign up with for example
google could also be like facebook
github lots of sites enables this
feature
and then they will be redirected to that
site and they will have to click on
accept that
our site can access their public profile
on the oauth site
and if they click accept they will be
redirected back and then we can retrieve
a token from that site
that will enable us to fetch some
some details about their profile
so from there we can choose if we want
to create a user on our site or if we're
gonna
keep a session from that site and just
access like their name their email
what we can access can be specified per
site
and i want to build this as simple as
possible we're going to have a
server on our side a simple little node
server that will handle these callbacks
and the redirections
the purpose is to show the simplest way
possible to achieve this
and in our example we're gonna use oauth
sign-in with github
so let's first take a look at github's
documentation for achieving this
and before this step one the user has
actually clicked on the button login or
sign up with github on your site
and then
step one is fired off here users are
redirected
to
request their github identity so they
are redirected from your domain to the
actual github.com domain
and if they click
allow
or if they sign in
they will be redirected back
and
this is a bit simplified we'll go into
more details
about how it actually works real soon
and then step three your app accesses
the api with the user's access token
so let's look deeper into step one
so the user gets redirected to
login or
authorize and we should have some url
parameters on this
url
so it's
client id
we can also have redirect uri
but we can also set that on the oauth
application on the settings in github
and we'll take a look at that as well
as you can see here the client id is the
only one that says required so we will
just care about these two for this
tutorial step two
so
users are redirected back and we will
get a code
as a parameter
it says here exchange this code for an
access token
so we will give the code and we will get
back an access token
and that token can then be used to
get data from that user's account at
github
but
i think it becomes clearer once we
actually start to try it out in the code
let's look at github
i have this test up here that we're
going to use
and i am under settings on my account
and then developer settings and then
under oauth apps
and here you can click new oauth app and
you can name it and you need to have a
home page url
and here is the
redirect uri that we looked at in the
documentation
so here
let's see what i have set for that in my
test app
so here
once we are done creating the app we get
a client id and a client secret and
those we have to use in our code
and down here i have set the
authorization callback url to localhost
since i am developing locally now
and then oauth callback so i need to
have a route that listens for the oauth
callback so i have saved the client id
and the client secret and of course i
will delete these afterwards you can
create your own if you want to follow
the guide
so now we are good to go
with
actually looking at the code
before we dig into the javascript let's
just look at the ui and inside the
server folder we actually have a little
front end here in the static map
and here we have the actual
html page
so as we can see we have some content
for when you're authorized
and some other content for when you're
not yet authorized
and let's
start the server and just look at this
markup and the styling that i've made
here we can see app listening on port
3000
so if i go to localhost 3000 i see here
happy to see your newcomer and sign in
with
github so if we look at our main dot or
our
server
file
we see that
on the root url we're actually just
serving this index.html file that i just
showed you and that's what happens in
this view
we have three routes in this app
the first one is
slash auth
and when we navigate to slash auth we
redirect the client towards github
and we go to you might remember this
from the documentation but it's login
slash oauth that's authorized we have a
url parameter from of client id
so here i use a package called dot end
and that allows me to specify some
variables in a dot n file
and then use them in here with process
dot end and then
the variable name
and it's important that i have this line
in the beginning of the file for that to
work
if we look
in the html file we see that the sign in
with github button is actually a link to
slash auth
so linking to slash auth triggers the
redirect to github
so
let's
set some break points in the server code
to verify that this works
so we've already seen the get
root that it works because we got the
index.html file
so now let's go to the font and actually
click
the link
and now nothing happens because we got
stuck on the breakpoint here
so if i press play we should be
redirected to this and see the client id
as a parameter
in the url
i will press play
and then we get redirected
so sign in to github to continue to test
app so now i need to sign into my github
account
and i don't want to show you the length
of my password so i will just do this
and now we signed in
and then we get redirected back
so now that i am logged in in this
browser the next time i do it it will
since i allow the application it will
just go
really fast
now i got stuck on the break point again
and i press play
and i just go to github i immediately
since i have a logged in session in this
browser i just get redirected back
immediately this is the
route that i get redirected back to so
let's stop inside here and see what
actually happens so now i click sign in
with github
and before i get
redirected back now
it's just waiting and that is because we
have this breakpoint here
so i just structured some data from the
callback here so we get an object that
has query and code
and this code is important for us
so i create this object called body that
has the client id and the client secret
and the code variable is added that we
get from github so now
if you remember from the documentation
we were supposed to get the access token
using this code
so we do a post to this url
and we pass in this body object so this
is the body and then we create some
headers
and call that
opts
so we do a post we pass in the body and
the headers
and then
when we get
a response
we parse out
the data.access token
and let's stop here
so now
we posted to github logging on with
access token and if everything went well
we received a token back from github
and that is this one here
so now we have the actual access token
but we have it on the server side
so here we could do like a request
directly and get the user's profile
and for this simple demo
i just did redirect
to the root url
and then i set a parameter
as the token
so we should be able to see the token
on the
client side
so i press play and if we go back to the
browser we have the github token here
let's also look at what happens on the
client side so here i have
just created two functions to hide and
show elements and that is because i want
to hide and show the unauthorized
content and the authorized content
so per default the authorized content is
hidden when we run this javascript code
if we have a token and the token is the
url parameter token if we have that we
hide unauthorized and we instead show
authorized so this is some very simple
demo code here
but that's all there is to it feel free
to
incorporate it for real in your own apps
and thank you so much for watching if
you like the content like the video and
be a subscriber
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video hopefully
you